al borde de una crisis alimentaria están
más de 12 millones de sirios tras el
terremoto de febrero y de más de una
década de guerra civil el programa
mundial de alimentos de la ONU alertó
que más de la mitad de la población
padece inseguridad alimentaria
solo en los próximos seis meses para
seguir haciendo llegar alimentos a las
familias pobres y hambrientas de Siria
necesitamos unos 450 millones de dólares
solo para mantener la asistencia Durante
los próximos seis meses si no
conseguimos este dinero lo antes posible
muchas familias sirias dejaran de
recibir asistencia porque ya no podremos
permitirnoslo
el sismo puso sobre la mesa los
problemas que enfrenta el país de
oriente medio donde han muerto por la
guerra alrededor de medio millón de
personas y ha sido desplazada a la mitad
de la población de esta nación de 23
millones de habitantes alepo fue la
región más devastada por el terremoto
con un 45% del total de los daños que
ascienden a unos 2.300 millones de
dólares
hay barrios en el hipo que casi han
desaparecido todos sus medios de vida
productivos los edificios los refugios
los lugares donde vivía la gente han
desaparecido Los afectados cuentan Cómo
ha sido su vida ante los acontecimientos
que enfrenta el país
la guerra fue difícil le hemos pasado
por muchas cosas como inseguridad
alimentaria hambre y bombardeos mataron
a mi marido y a mi hermano pero incluso
los días de guerra fueron más fáciles
para mí que los tiempos actuales
el Banco Mundial declaró a principios de
este mes que todas Siria había sufrido
unos daños estimados en 5.100 millones
de dólares tras el terremoto